all hail the queen of Halloween Kylie
Jenner proved she does the spooky
holiday better than literally everyone
else
cheering this video of her with her
bestie Stassi yep
that's the reality star and her friend
recreating one of the most iconic pop
star moments of all time
you know that time Madonna and Britney
Spears smooshed onstage at the 2003 MTV
Video Music Awards
[Music]
okay so Kylie and stassi's version was a
little bit sillier and honestly you guys
I'm a little bit concerned that one of
them may have cracked a tooth and while
they may not have nailed the kiss
they definitely nailed their costumes
cool cool
earlier in the day Kylie teased her
costume posting a clip of her listening
to Brits 2007 hit piece of me on her
instace Tori
[Music]
of course this isn't the first time that
Kylie has channeled her in her early
2000s pop princess in 2016
she had the internet completely shook
dressed up as Christina Aguilera circa
her dirty era yeah like I said queen of
Halloween the only member of the famous
family who might have Kylie beat is her
20 month old daughter stormy who dressed
up in full head-to-toe costume as
drumroll please her mom
[Music]
stormy straight-up broke the cuteness
meter dressed up in a mini version of
Kylie's Met Gala look we are talking
purple Peeta dress a feather boa and
purple wig people I mean
I'm dead it's too good Kylie shared a
few pics and this clip of the Halloween
look on Instagram alongside the caption
my baby I can't handle this complete
with a ton of purple heart emojis same
girl same I cannot wait to see what the
rest of the Kardashians have planned for
Halloween and honestly I'm kind of
hoping they do another sister costume
remember last year they did a full-on
professional photo shoot to capture
their Victoria's Secret Angels costumes
and they damn near broke the Internet of
course et will be right here to make
sure you are all caught up on the
kardashian-jenner x' so make sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]